why does she keep looking up at the
tower
because she thinks there's still hope
that's a scene from wolf hall the
six-part mini-series starring mark
rylance damien lewis and claire foy
about the rise of thomas cromwell
in 16th century england as he served
under henry viii
wolf hall and the two books that
followed was first of best-selling
trilogy of historical novels from
acclaimed author hillary mantell
we spoke to mentel recently at her home
in devon on the coast of england four
hours outside london about the success
she's had why she's now leaving england
and another work a series of short
stories based on her childhood being
released in the united states for the
first time it is called learning to talk
in learning to talk
whilst not writing like a child i'm
trying to give
some
feeling of the child's world how the
child's mind operates
hillary mental grew up in a working
working-class irish immigrant
neighborhood in the north of england
it was not an easy childhood
when she was six years old her mother
moved another man into the family home
while mantell's father was still living
there
you were deeply scarred
by your childhood have you come to terms
with that
well an unhappy childhood is a treasure
for a writer not to be cynical about it
but happy childhoods don't produce many
good stories
so the whole point about being a writer
or career
is that you take the bad things and you
use them you extract some good out of
them
for years mantell has produced not just
good
but great stories
most famously her works based on the
life of thomas cromwell the english
statesman who served as counselor to
henry viii i thought this is great this
is just an audio of a man from nowhere
who climbs right to the top of the
hierarchy
how does he do it
question where are you from putney left
when i was a boy by mining cromwell's
rise mantel produced a best-selling
trilogy that led to the wolf hall tv
miniseries he knows that all the king's
subjects propose their hopes in you for
an heir to the throne very nice
very nice master clermon
but try again
and she became only the fifth writer
ever to receive the booker prize
twice
when i began the book i knew i had to do
something very difficult
i had to interest the historians
i had to amuse the jaded palette of the
critical establishment
most of all i had to capture the
imagination
of the general reader
in learning to talk mantel combines
fiction and truth to confront the trauma
of her youth
how much of learning you talk is
biographical
and how much is fiction
i said
in my little introduction
that it's not really autobiographical
it's autoscopic
if you get outside your own body
and you saw a double of yourself but
that double had a slightly different
story
that's how the book works
it's more raw
oh much more raw
and
close to the bone
mantel's previously written other work
more focused on her adult life
including details of her decades-long
struggle with endometriosis
which led to a failed surgery that left
her unable to have children
as she pursued her writing career she
lived in botswana and saudi arabia
mantel got married then divorced then
remarried the same man the next year
eventually gerald mcewen gave up his job
as a geologist to manage mantel's
intense schedule when you're deep in the
middle of something now you still
disappear for
days or
long stretches
oh i disappear internally for about
three years or as long as it takes
and i'm just a puppet who says certain
step phrases
and eats when reminded and
yeah i mean my how lovely for your
husband
yes i mean he's
he's got used to relating to the puppet
by now mantel told us she is once again
deep in the process of working on a new
historical novel
she also said she and mcewen just made a
big decision
they are leaving england
brexit
they bought a house in ireland
britain's leaving
the european union it's not something
we've managed to come to terms with in
the years since it happened
so we want to go back to one and get our
irish passports and uh and be part of
the big story again
why did that damage you so much
i've always thought of myself
as a regional author that is
coming from the north of england
and a european author
and those have been my identities i've
always thought my heritage is european
and i strenuously object to having that
confiscated
wow
bought that house already the way that
hillary she mixes real history both in
what she's written about herself and
thomas cromwell the way she mixes real
history with her own imagination
is unlike anything else that's a gift oh
yeah not easy to do oh yeah yeah it was
interesting too when she said that the
horrible past experiences
that that is
extracting so many good yeah so many
authors do yeah i love that she has
definitive ideas in in politics
she's really
laying down the gauntlet you know
anybody like that
a few people yeah